on est aujourd'hui à Enigma 78 au
village des loisirs à Maurepas c'est le
premier quiz game des Yvelines donc
comme dans un jeu télévisé le principe
est simple répondent à quelques
questions sur l'actualité le sport le
cinéma alors j'ai donné un défi à ma
collègue Mélanie prête pour ce défi j'ai
bien révisé après prête je ne sais pas
on va voir ça on y va
voyage voyage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un bon challengeur j'ai gagné c'est plus
important non c'est vraiment sympa il y
a plein de thèmes nous on c'est
peut-être un petit peu embourbé dans la
musique des années 80 mais moi j'ai
appris plein de choses un petit peu de
cinéma
après c'est selon les goûts et en
fonction du groupe qui joue mais non non
vraiment sympa donc là on a joué à deux
joueurs mais les équipes conseillent de
jouer à trois joueurs minimum on peut
jouer jusqu'à 6 personnes la partie dure
50 minutes environ et c'est 22 euros par
personne énigma 78 est ouvert donc 7
jours sur 7 de 10 heures et la dernière
partie est à 22h
j'irai plus haut que ces montagnes de
douleurs en rouge et noir